merci ma chère brigitte et cher bruno je
suis heureux de pouvoir intervenir dans
ce débat
d'abord une chose la loi de 2007 se
trouve que j'étais ministre délégué de
nicolas sarkozy que j'ai donc eu à
porter un grand nombre de son contenu à
la fois devant l'assemblée le sénat et
je crois qu'elle a donné beaucoup plus
de pouvoir à la fois au maire et au
président du conseil général qu on ne le
mesure et qu'on ne le dit et je suis
très heureux d'avoir écouté alexandre
caroline et bernard qui ont démontré
combien il savait la mettre en oeuvre
dans leur commune que ce soit de petites
communes des moyennes communes ou une
grandes communes comme marseille et avec
beaucoup de talent et en même temps
faire des propositions innovantes et il
faut faire la différence entre le maire
et la police municipale il ya le pouvoir
du maire et il y a bien évidemment les
fonctionnaires territoriaux que sont des
policiers municipaux qui exercent sous
l'autorité du maire est important de
préciser qu'un grand nombre de polices
municipales sont même en désaccord avec
leur mère ou plutôt que c'est un grand
nombre de maires dans notre pays qui
sont en désaccord avec leur police
municipale
lorsque je parle de ces désaccords ce
sont des maires de gauche pour la
plupart du temps bon tant que vice
président de l'association des maires de
france
autant vous dire que ces dernières
années j'ai été confronté pour exercer
au sein du ministère de l'intérieur
encore aujourd'hui au nom de
l'association des maires de france
la présidence de la commission
consultative des polices municipales de
france cette dualité entre le fait que
les la plupart des syndicats de police
municipale je dis bien la plupart
souhaitent pouvoir agir 24 heures sur 24
jour et nuit à voir leur statut qui pour
la plupart du temps sont de catégorie c
de la fonction publique territoriale
sans prime de risque contrairement la
gendarmerie ou à la police nationale et
finissent donc leur carrière à un niveau
de retraite et de revenus qui est absent
du moins supportable alors que lorsque
l'on voit dans quelles conditions
aurélie fouquet et clarissa jean
baptiste ont été tuées et pourtant c'est
la même prise de risque le coc des
policiers nationaux ou des gendarmes
lorsque alexandre parler de ces petites
caméras je peux vous dire que si aurélie
fouquet avait eu une petite caméra comme
celle là aurélie fouquet ne serait pas
morte parce qu'on n'aurait pas envoyé au
casse-pipe face à une attaque d'un
fourgon de transport de fonds où elle
n'avait aucune indication pour pouvoir
savoir comment se positionner et se
protéger elle-même
donc ça montre bien que quand il ya une
vraie coordination entre le maire et sa
police municipale
forcément la police municipale et en os
pause ça marche et ça marche plutôt bien
le problème c'est que beaucoup de maires
veulent surtout qu'on en donne le moins
possible à la police municipale se
disant au fond plus ça reste de la
responsabilité de l'état plus je me
décharge sur l'état et mieux c'est et en
même temps ils ont pas envie de répondre
aux revendications d'une police
municipale qui demande d'être rémunéré
mieux d'être classée avec les primes qui
sont les mêmes que celles des forces de
l'état alors que la police municipale en
france retenait ce chiffre représente
20% des forces de sécurité intérieures
de notre pays
20 % c'est-à-dire quand le ministre de
l'intérieur à la fin de l'année nous
c'était tous les mois je le rappelle
éric ont donné les statistiques tous les
mois tous les mois à la hausse ou à la
baisse peu importe on disait la vérité
aux français
on a fait baisser de temps on a monté
temps la sécurité on a fait baisser pts
en on est montés temps sur les taux
d'élucidation
il y avait un observatoire tous les mois
hollande est arrivé valls est arrivé à
l'intérieur plus d'observatoire tous les
mois plus de statistiques tous les mois
une fois par an au moment où le
procureur de la république dans chaque
département ou dans chaque juridiction
fait son rapport et où globalement le
ministre de l'intérieur de mes résultats
et quand le ministre de l'intérieur
10 par exemple nous avons un taux
d'élucidation de 28 % c'est-à-dire 28 %
de faits élucidés il dit pas quelle est
la part de la gendarmerie il dit pas
quelle est la part de la police
nationale et 10 paquets la part de la
police municipale eh bien il faut savoir
que la part de la police municipale et
200%
elle est de 100% parce que la police
municipale n'a le droit d'intervenir
comme le rappelait bernard notamment sur
les contrôles d'identité quand flagrant
délit et forcément comme un flagrant
délit est un fait élucidé
la parc s'attribue le ministère de
l'intérieur dans les taux d'élucidation
qu'il soit 2,25 de 28 2 32%
c'est pour la part de la police
municipale de 100% parce qu'il n'ya
qu'en cas de flagrant délit que nous
pouvons interpeller quelqu'un et à
partir de là s'engage tout un processus
épouvantable le remettre entre les mains
d'un au pgi puisque on nous refuse de
leur accorder au moins le statut eux
d'un pgi à que ne pouvons même pas leur
permettre de contacter le fichier stic
vous avez des institutions des banquiers
qui peuvent contacter le fichier stic
dans notre pays
lorsque vous intervenez interpellé à un
automobiliste en infraction simplement
téléphoné pour savoir si les fichiers
s'il a son permis de conduire s'il a
bien tous ces points s'il a existé et
caetera et bien la police municipale
n'est pas autorisé à le faire alors bien
évidemment dans les villes chacun se
tourner vers le maire en pensant que le
verbe peut tout faire que sida il ya de
l'insécurité sa cause du maire que si un
problème d'incivilité
d'ailleurs c'est un mot que je n'aime
pas c'est un mot inventé par les
socialistes du temps de chevènement
disaient les sauvageons et on disait les
et les faits d'incivilité
voilà pour moi un sauvageon c'est un
sauvageon c'est un voyou et un faits
d'incivilité en réalité c'est une
atteinte à l'intégrité morale ou
physique grave à l'égard d'un de nos
concitoyens et il faudrait que là aussi
les républicains soient capables
d'inventer leur propre vocabulaire leurs
propres mots qui parlent aux françaises
et aux français par rapport à toujours
ce discours aseptisé de la gauche bien
pensante qui essaient toujours de
minimiser la responsabilité des uns et
des autres en matière d'insécurité
donc je vous dis tout cela parce que le
maire police municipale pas police
municipale a d'abord son propre pouvoir
de police mon cher bruno c'est pas toi
que je l'expliqué moi je sais que j'ai
utilisé toute la palette
j'ai été d'ailleurs déferré je ne sais
combien de fois dans les tribunaux
administratifs pour avoir utilisé toute
la palette les arrêté de couvre feu pour
les mineurs de moins de 13 ans j'avais
dit
21h on m'a dit non c'est minuit les
arrêtés anti regroupement et et voyez ce
que je veux dire quand je parle des
regroupements mais je veux pas les
qualifier pour pas me retrouver devant
un tribunal correctionnel
donc on m'a dit oui mais simplement de
10h à 12h et de 14h à 18h c'est à dire
que le reste du temps vous ne pouvez
rien faire
les arrêtés notamment pour la bonne
tenue des mariages quand je vois dans
quelles conditions nous sommes obligés
de célébrer un certain nombre de
mariages vous dit samedi dernier parce
qu'un couple n'a pas respecté la charte
d'engagements des futurs mariés à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas n'importe quoi qui
soit fait en termes de gymkhana sur la
chaussée public de sortir des drapeaux
étrangers alors qu'on se rend devant
marianne et cetera j'ai moi même reçu
les deux futurs époux et j'ai dit c'est
annulé c'est reporté à plus tard
et si la prochaine fois la prochaine
date qu'on reprendra vous tenez bien eh
ben on célèbrera le mariage mais pour
mener tous ses combats pour mener tous
ses combats
croyez-moi déjà pour le maire pour faire
appliquer ces arrêtés qui doivent être
appliquées autant par la police
municipale par la police nationale que
la par la gendarmerie nationale
c'est pas facile donc la première
responsabilité du maire est une
responsabilité de police d'ailleurs il
est lui-même officier de police
judiciaire
d'accord mais à deuxièmement la police
municipale il ya ceux qui aiment la
police municipale et qui comme bernard
comme alexandre comme caroline qui fonde
un travail formidable et c'est de leur
donner des moyens d'agir et c'est de
compenser tout ce que l'état refuse que
nous leur donnions la revalorisation de
leur statut une retraite qui les amène
un meilleur niveau des catégories b
voire une catégorie a pour un directeur
de police municipale au moins à partir
d'un effectif de 20 personnes et s'était
autant de sujets l'armement ou
aujourd'hui on nous accorde du sein un
pistolet avec un chargeur où il faut
remettre six balles dès que vous en
tirez qui font plus
au bout de trente mètres et donc ils
font peur aucun délinquant phase là où
il y a des armes automatiques entre les
mains de la police nationale alors
qu'ils ont la même formation les mêmes
tirs d'entraînement dans les mêmes
centres de tirs d'entraînement et cetera
et cetera et que forcément c'est plus
facile de remettre un chargeur en 30
secondes quand vous avez une bande de
loubards en face de vous et que vous
êtes en situation de légitime défense et
qu'il faut pouvoir y répondre
absolument sans compter le fait qu'on ne
nous autorise pas à utiliser les armes
non létales comme les taser ou comme les
flashs balle dans les mêmes conditions
juridiques qu'on autorise la police
nationale nous ne pouvons les utiliser
que de manière défensive et pas de
manière offensive alors que nous savons
que ce sont des armes est inoffensive
physiquement mais qu'ils peuvent mais en
même temps peuvent permettre de
neutraliser beaucoup plus facilement un
délinquant qui est en face alors vous
dire tout cela c'est en même temps
répondre à cette question qui m'est
proposée par brigitte sur le fait
qu'effectivement on peut libérer
beaucoup d'effectifs et les rend plus
disponible
est il normal au moment où on aux
baisses de dotations globales de
fonctionnement où on nous met les
rythmes scolaires quand même temps le
maire qui se sent responsable et qui est
plutôt du côté des républicains
la plupart du temps un soit trop
aujourd'hui en responsabilité par
rapport à ses concitoyens obligé de
dépenser des sommes non négligeables en
matière de charges de fonctionnement
recrutant les policiers municipaux
conséquent chez moi j'en ai 380 plus de
150 svp là où j'ai simplement 750
policiers nationaux pour une huile de
380 mille habitants et sur ses 750
policiers nationaux je n'ai jamais pu
obtenir du préfet la juste répartition
entre ce qu'ils sont des personnels
administratifs et ceux qui sont des
personnels sur le terrain alors que les
miens ne sont que des personnels sur le
terrain c'est à dire qu'on voit dans ma
ville plus aux policiers municipaux
convois de policiers
nationaux donc effectivement aujourd'hui
dire à des transporteurs de fonds dont
le métier est déclinant d'ailleurs parce
que tout est de plus en plus sécurisés
grâce aux lois sarkozy d'ailleurs dans
ce domaine aussi plutôt que de mettre au
chômage un certain nombre de personnes
qui n'ont plus de raison d'être
employées dans des transports de fonds
vous allez faire du transport de
prisonniers
ça permettra de libérer des personnes
des personnels qui font les
transfèrements des prisons jusque vers
les palais de justice et c'est à dire
aux sociétés autoroutières qui
aujourd'hui ont en charge la gestion de
la sécurité routière
que ce soit sur le balisage que ce soit
sur l'entretien que ce soit sur les
aires de stationnement
que ce soit sur la gestion du péage
autoroutier et cetera vous avez aussi
une part de responsabilité assumée et
pas laisser à la simple gendarmerie
autoroutière le fait de devoir remplir
cette mission
bien évidemment et enfin au moment et je
termine là dessus ou c'est le candidat
la conquête de la présidence de la
région provence alpes côte d'azur qui
vous parle et où j'ai la chance d'avoir
des amis comme caroline aux côtés de
jean claude gaudin est mon ami bernard
reynès qui est un maire extrêmement
offensif et qui dans notre formation
politique joue un rôle important qu'ils
sont engagés à mes côtés utilisé à la
fois les nouveaux pouvoirs qui peuvent
être attribuées à des présidents de
région puisqu'ils ont en charge les
transports express régionaux ferroviaire
et en même temps mutualisé avec les
communes voir les intercommunalités les
nouvelles technologies combien de fois
ne nous sommes on nous retrouver avec
caroline dans des seaux b sur les smart
cities et sur les nouvelles technologies
au service de la sécurité
récemment encore à tel aviv
c'est à chaque fois la possibilité avec
une caméra est hyper performante puisque
il ya des logiciels intelligents
aujourd'hui la capacité de remplacer 10
15 20 policiers
on nous dit toujours on a fait baisser
les effectifs
d'abord on n'a pas fait baisser ses
effectifs ses 35 heures qui ont fait
baisser effectif
c'est ça la réalité qu'on ne rappelle
pas suffisamment souvent les 35 heures
de monsieur jospin s'est immédiatement
25% de policiers en moins sur l'ensemble
de la voie publique mais en même temps
en même temps lorsque l'on voit
qu'aujourd'hui avec la biométrie l'iris
de l'oeil dans les lieux de grande
circulation vous voyez ces
démonstrations qui vous sont faites dans
des startups à tel aviv par exemple vous
voyez dans des flux de 200 300 personnes
299 carré vert autour des visages et
puis tout d'un coup un carré rouge
autour d'un visage parce que c'est un
visage qui est fiché je peux vous dire
que ça règlerait bien des problèmes
aujourd'hui utilisé toutes les méthodes
qui peuvent exister en matière de
technologie et donc pour les trains moi
je le dis c'est dans mon projet et je le
mettrai en oeuvre dès 2016 dans ma
renégociation avec la convention avec la
sncf j'entendais monsieur cazenove qui
l'autre jour disait après l'incident du
thalys qui est quand même pas n'importe
quelle affaire qui nous a permis de
révéler à la france entière qui avait
5000 personnes qui étaient fichés s
c'est à dire sûreté d'état de sas 16es
16 qui seraient les moins dangereux aux
ordres de dèche et est scindé des
terroristes potentiels extrêmement
dangereux celui du thalys étaient est
roi et monsieur hollande qui vers ses
larmes de crocodile le lendemain comme
d'habitude en disant voilà on est passé
à côté d'un drame épouvantable
heureusement qu'il y avait ces deux
militaires américains
bon bah dites moi vous savez qu'il ya
5000 personnes qui sont fichés s 5000
pourquoi vous leur faites pas porte un
bracelet électronique à chacun et celui
qui était dans le thalys étaient fichier
est roi c'est quand même pas le moins
dangereux
monsieur 15/09/10
magie l'idée on va faire de la fouille
au corps dans les gares pardon si vous
voulez faire entrer les trains qui déjà
sont tous en retard dans notre pays et
faire en sorte que les gens montent à
l'heure dans les trains ça va pas être
une affaire facile donc jeudi dans cette
convention jeu renégocierait j'imposerai
qu'il y ait des portiques on dit oui
mais les portiques les portiques c'est
ça va être extrêmement longue
ça sera sûrement pas plus long qu la
fouille au corps et en plus de cela les
les portiques on sait que ça se règle
dans les aéroports on sait qu'avec une
boucle de ceinture ça se déclenche
mais si on les règles pour que ça ses
planches comme pour l'autre qui est
monté avec trois pistolets mitrailleurs
et quatre grenades sous la veste
permettez moi de vous dire qu'on réglera
beaucoup de problèmes
deuxièmement la vidéosurveillance vous
avez aujourd'hui les technologies les
plus avancées que des logiciels
extrêmement intelligent et bien mettre
dans nos systèmes nos transports
ferroviaires et noram des caméras de
vidéo surveillance tels que j'ai émises
en mai transport interurbain alors on me
dit mais c'est injouable sur l'ensemble
des trains régionaux
les trains régionaux ça représente 85
mille usagers jours mais transport
intérêt au mas en représente 230 mille
jours donc moi je ne suis pas un
commentateur
je suis un acteur et je les ai mises en
place au lendemain des attentats du mois
de janvier
mon opposition du front national
dites-le a voté contre
au conseil municipal d'ailleurs pour
jouer en place et caméras et en même
temps la délinquance a baissé en moins
de trois semaines dès que nous les avons
installé dans les transports de 90%
parce qu'un transport ferroviaire un
transport en commun en site propre c'est
un lieu fermé avec une police des
transports et avec les hautes
technologies automatiquement à la
station d'arrêt suivante vous êtes
arrêté donc vous savez que vous ne
passez pas à travers je prends cet
exemple pour conclure diversi pour te
dire simplement et pour vous dire à
chacune et à chacun d'entre vous que ce
sont autant de sujets où nous avons la
compétence où nous avons l'expérience où
nous avons la possibilité de
à la conquête des régions déjà sur 13
réseau ferroviaire dans notre pays
si nous mettons ces savoir faire en
commun d'apporter dans l'opposition
nationale des réponses à l'ensemble des
citoyens français que le gouvernement
français est incapable d'apporter
aujourd'hui et ça peut être une victoire
dans la lutte contre l'insécurité tout
de suite ça peut changer tout de suite
dès 2016 sans avoir à attendre 2017
voilà en tout cas ce que je voulais vous
proposer bravo